.
SO IT'S GOING TO GET SPICY.
TULSI GABBARD IS A FORMER 2020
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE WHO JUST
LEFT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
SHE JOINS US NOW.
SO HOW FAR DO YOU INTERPRET
WHETHER A WENT DOWN IN THE HOUSE
LAST NIGHT?
>> JESSE, I'M NOT A POLITICAL
PUNDIT, BUT I CAN TELL YOU GIVEN
THE DIRECTION THAT THINGS ARE
HEADED, I THINK THE THING THAT'S
MOST IMPORTANT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IS WHETHER THEY ARE
DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS, DO
YOUR JOB.
DON'T JUST WORRY ABOUT WHICH
TEAM WON, WHICH TEAM LOST?
HOW DO WE STRATEGIZE AND
MANEUVER ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR TEAM WINS IN THE NEXT
ELECTION.
THERE IS SO MANY VERY, VERY REAL
ISSUES AND CHALLENGES THAT
PEOPLE ARE DEALING WITH EVERY
DAY IN THIS COUNTRY AND THEY
EXPECT THESE PEOPLE WHO JUST GOT
ELECTED OR REELECTED TO ACTUALLY
GO THERE, DO THEIR JOB, AND
ADVOCATE FOR THEM RATHER THAN
JUST PURSUING PARTISAN
INTERESTS.
>> Jesse: IF THEY DO LAUNCH A
SLEW OF INVESTIGATIONS, WHICH
ARE WORTHY, DO YOU THINK THE
VOTERS ARE GOING TO SAY HEY,
GUYS, CAN YOU CUT THAT PARTISAN
STUFF OUT?
CAN YOU TRY TO FIX INFLATION OR
CRIME OR THE BORDER?
>> I THINK EVERY DECISION REALLY
DOES NEED TO BE WEIGHED ON HOW
DOES THIS BEST SERVE THE
WELL-BEING AND THE INTEREST OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY, AND OUR
COUNTRY.
SO I KNOW THE REPUBLICANS ARE
TALKING ABOUT A WHOLE SLEW OF
DIFFERENT THINGS.
WHAT THEY REALLY SHOULD BE DOING
IS WEIGHING EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF THEM BASED ON THAT CONTEXT.
HOW DOES THIS BEST SERVE THE
WELL-BEING OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY AND LET
THAT BE -- LET THAT BE THE
GUIDELINES AND THE NORTH STAR IN
HOW THEY MAKE THEIR DECISIONS.
>> Jesse: THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DO BOTH.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT OF THE AND FIND OUT
WHAT THE JOE BIDEN FAMILY IS UP
TO.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Jesse: FIND OUT WHAT'S GOING
DOWN AT THE BORDER AND ALSO CUT
THESE PURSE STRINGS IN HALF
BECAUSE THINFLATION AND SPENDING
IS OUT OF CONTROL.
WHAT WOULD BE THE FIRST THING IF
THERE WAS A SPEAKER TULSI
GABBARD?
WHAT WOULD BE THE FIRST THING
YOU WOULD LAUNCH OFF WITH IN THE
NEW CONGRESS?
>> OOOF, THAT'S A TOUGH QUESTION
BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT OF
PRIORITIES DEALING WITH
INFLATION HAS GOT TO BE THE TOP
OF THE LIST BECAUSE I HAVE JUST
MET OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS
TRAVELING THE COUNTRY A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO ARE REALLY REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
GOING TO AFFORD TO PAY THEIR
HEATING BILL AND ALSO TAKE CARE
OF THE BASIC NECESSITIES THEY
NEED TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
I WOULD ADDRESS AND UNDO ALL OF
THE INCREDIBLE OVERREACH OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION, ABUSING THEIR
EXECUTIVE POWER AND VIOLATING
OUR FUNDAMENTAL GOD-GIVEN RIGHTS
AND FREEDOMS IN THE CONSTITUTION
AND WORK ON THE CRIME.
CRIME IS OUT OF CONTROL AND
SECURING OUR BORDER.
I THINK THOSE ARE REALLY THE TOP
PRIORITIES THAT HAVE AN EFFECT
ON OUR EVERY DAY LIVES THAT MUST
BE TACKLED BY LEADERS IN
WASHINGTON.
>> Jesse: IS IT TRUE THAT A
NONMEMBER OF CONGRESS CAN BE
SPEAKER BECAUSE THERE ARE RUMORS
THAT YOU MIGHT BE -- I'M JUST
KIDDING.
I'M JUST KIDDING.
>> YEAH, I K